bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur sur des
gonades et aujourd'hui nous allons
parler du tournoi du cap d'agde qui
s'est déroulé et bien juste avant l'open
de corse et après donc le tournoi ou
bovine sous judit polgar a battu topalov
par 2 à 0 et nous recevons pour parler
de ce tournoi cap d'agde et de beaucoup
d'autres choses
une des grandes stars des échelles
français puisqu'il est présent sur la
scène française depuis longtemps il a
été secondes en un tollé karpov un des
premiers grands maîtres français aussi
c'est olivier rhône et bonjour bonjour
stéphane alors effectivement tu fais
partie on peut dire de la première
génération un peu les chevaliers
français qui ont un peu débroussailler
le terrain de la maîtrise des échecs les
pionniers itunes disons que les bons les
vrais pionniers
moi mon avis il en france en tout cas
aldo haïk donc avait déjà posé la
première pierre puisque c'était le
premier maître international donc qu'il
a ouvert la voie aux français ensuite
il ya eu de nombreux français moi je me
souviens j'étais 13e maître
international donc déjà sa salive quito
et donc ensuite effectivement je suis
devenu un des premiers grands maîtres à
une époque où ce où il y avait deux
choses qui n'existaient pas par rapport
aux jeunes donc l'appui par
l'informatique était très très peu
utilisé ou étaient venus dans le grand
bain du corps dans les fan des années 80
89 97 comme ça et la deuxième chose
c'est comme les russes étaient encore
chez eux le mur de berlin n'était pas
encore tombée on avait très peu de
soviétiques des joueurs de l'ess qui
venait donc on était un peu livrés à
nous mêmes sans entraîneur avec
l'entraîneur étranger et il y avait que
les livres auxquels informatiques
existants à tout ça suffit a priori mais
moi c'est une autre génération avec
d'autres moyens et c'est vrai que
maintenant bon on a beaucoup de grands
maîtres en france
bon c'est vrai que c'est j'ai pu
contribuer à démarrer quelque chose
ouais enfin ça c'est clair
en plus si peter arthur tu avais tu as
participé à aussi au développement et a
suivi les aventures des premiers grands
événements en france le trophée chopard
notamment que j'étais commentateurs de
ce trophée les champs elysées des champs
elysées un grand évènement est
exactement un grand spectacle quoi tu as
une des premières fois où les échecs
finalement été présenté comme un
spectacle avec la volonté
dans le faire un spectacle en spectacle
c'est à dire d'une mise en scène de la
musique un cadre et puis les grands noms
et tout ça en partie rapide
oui ça avait fait un peu grincer des
dents 18 des parties rapides c'est pas
des échéances a en fait on s'aperçoit
maintenant que ce soit parce qu'il ya du
spectacle que ça empêche les parties des
choses qui vont très bien sans
complémentaire ou danser des bons
souvenirs sa voiture et alors donc je
peux dire il ya un moment où je dirais
tu as presque en fâcher pas c'était
c'était un je ne sais pas peut-être dès
ce moment de ta carrière quand même
c'est que tu as été choisi par la tôle
karpov pour préparer son match face à
kas parents ça c'était un honneur
immense ah oui c'est sûr qu'ils sont
tous des responsabilités
oui c'est à dire que c'est un
c'est une chance quoi finalement d'avoir
été là où je m'en rende plus contre
maintenant que à l'époque
ouais quand on est dedans on fait des
trucs qui vous avions fait 100% où on
voit pas trop quoi il c'est vrai que au
niveau français il ya deux joueurs qui
ont été dans un staff de championnat du
monde c'est c'est joël lautier avec des
crânes ikram nique à l'ombre rendre à
londres en 2003 et contre kasparov oui
et donc mois contre saran faut 6 400 ce
qui est intéressant finalement c'est
d'arriver à être de rentrer à
l'intérieur d'un camp qui n'est pas
vraiment du monde et ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur c'est ça qu'on a envie de
savoir passer quand clic dans la cuisine
à l'intérieur des grands maîtres
derrière dans l'arrière-cour il se passe
quoi c'est pour la cuisine qu'est ce qui
se passe là mais bon il ya évidemment il
ya la cuisine et chez qui elle dit
combien c'était assez bien
compartimenter il y avait la garde
rapprochée de karpov c'est à dire ça y
est c'est fait
ben gaied van canh très grand entre
conjoints donné son nom à cette époque
gates quelles avancées des joueurs qui
suivent car pop depuis les années 70
donc ils sont au courant de tout c'est
les seuls qui sont grandes tout tout
tout tout tout tout cas une savent tout
et presque tous parce que karpov il dit
pas toujours ce qu'il veut faire donc il
ya que karpov qui se tourne sous ya la
garde rapprochée
si après il ya d'autres éléments donc
moi je faisais partie des éléments qui
venaient des pays de l'ouest
oui avec moi il y avait un mec était
aussi un ami de cap horn où on avait de
la chance de cette époque là de l'un des
éléments phares de son équipe c'était
l'agent sportif donné pas mal d'idées
dans les ouvertures et puis il y avait
deux jeunes y avait un lexique aux mines
et puis avait aussi un autre joueur
russe dont j'ai oublié le nom là tout de
suite
voilà donc en fait la cuisine c'est quoi
c'est que karpov c'est quelqu'un qui a
joué de nombreux championnats du monde
donc c'est toute une organisation vous
avez parapsychologue les cuisiner le
professeur de tennis
c'est beaucoup de monde c'est une
organisation ultra professionnel
d'accord mais alors qu'est ça on peut
pas le connaître quel est ton rôle doit
nous moi notre rôle c'était purement
technique voilà on avait des variantes à
regarder donné le jugement tu as qu'on
allait voir
karpov prenez le résultat est là ça va
là ça va pas maintenant vous faites
autre chose voilà donc on a des bouts de
boulot à faire on fait ensuite on doit
rendre compte et ensuite on voit ce
qu'on peut améliorer on fait des
réunions entre nous et c'est donc c'est
le boulot à l'époque il est
essentiellement un travail couverture
quand même alors juste lanseria c'est un
téléphone qui sonne c'est pas grave ça
va s'arrêter
voilà c'est ça le travail du second dans
techniquement tels que moi j'ai fait
c'est un travail d'ouverture
essentiellement d'accord ce qu'a fait
aussi l'outil akram knicks étaient aussi
beaucoup de préparation dans les
ouvertures beaucoup de travail ça
demande beaucoup de travail en avance
cependant quoi sachant qu'elle s'était
proclamé y avait pas les bases de
données c'est donc tout ça veut dire que
karpov savez en gros donc les grandes
banques lui voulu analyser que ce soit
clément avec les blancs en face à
kasparov
c'est lui qui donnait ses indications là
et qu'en fait toi tu étais donc en bout
de chaîne des indes est un des grands
maîtres qui analyse et un certain type
de mal à sa devise c'est ce qui va jouer
il sait ce qu'il veut laisser le seul
qui sait ce qui va jouer
passé le temps de le dire à personne ne
dit pas mais sur celui il faillit doit
avoir des discussions avec c'est ça que
j'appelle sa garde rapprochée qui le
connaissent depuis longtemps où ils leur
soumet l'idée mais je pense que même
certaines parties ya que lui qui sait ce
qui va jouer lendemain en personne s'est
par contre il a tout un travail à sa
disposition et il choisit d'après son
expérience d'après sa forme du moment
d'après ce qu'ils pensent être le
meilleur choix
d'accord donc c'était très enrichissant
pour savoir comment se prépare et
finalement ça du de servir pour ta
propre préparation aussi peut-être oui
oui nommer ces organisations c'est comme
je dis bon par exemple
aux personnes qui connaissent pas bien
les échecs c'est comme si vous êtes un
jeune musicien et vous allez avec miles
davis
oui enregistré enfin paraître pendant
deux mois immergé dans une maison à
faire du jazz
voilà on a tout de suite tout compris
cette karpov se fait partie des grands
grand grand bien sûr je ans d'échec
donc quand ils donnent une indication de
quelque chose qui ne va pas dans le
travail qu'on a fait bon c'est quelque
chose qui reste donc encore bondi en
plus c'était en france en même temps
c'est un championnat du monde c'était
totalement passionnant c'est vrai qu'à
cette époque la carpe a fêté en dessous
par rapport à kasparov qui avait déjà
pris l'ascendant
oui donc ce n'était pas aussi serré et
un certain que les championnats qui
avait eu lieu quelques années avant
notamment celui de 87 qui c'est qui a
failli tourner à la fin voilà il faut
savoir qu'ils ont joué plus de 165
partis ensemble donc nos matches donc ça
fait beaucoup ça fait beaucoup quand
c'est bon ça fait beaucoup
et alors donc donc aujourd'hui tu t'es
tu t'es un peu maintenant orientée vers
l'entraînement donc tu entraînes des
jeunes joueurs ou des jeunes déjà de
mettre aussi froid que tu as été
entraîneur de je vais peut-être dire une
bêtise mais de maxime
non non mais disons que je les ai eus
quand il avait 10 ans voilà maxime
vachier lagrave n'existe plus tôt par
arnaud wim chars et puis par lui-même
sur blessure mais sûrement non moi
disons que j'étais membre de l'équipe de
france joue que j'étais grand maître
donc j'ai continué dans l'équipe de
france j'ai essayé de jouer au plus haut
niveau français dans toutes les
compétitions internationales jusqu'à peu
près 98
oui voilà et à partir de ce moment là
j'ai commencé petit à petit à m'orienter
vers le métier d'entraîneur si j'ai une
suite logique c'est une suite logique en
même temps il ya des grands maîtres qui
n'aime pas du tout enseigner moi je sais
j'avais cette double casquette j'ai
toujours aimé commenter enseigner parler
d échec
et finalement c'est quelque chose de
passionnant pour moi un bon alors donc
c'était logique quoi quelque part il ya
le dernier point tu as appris les
chèques tard j'ai ramené à 15 ans je
crois un peu un petit peu avant 12 13
ans commencée voilà donc c'est
relativement tarde pas si on regarde les
champions du monde qui ont appris à
quatre ou cinq ans qui ont commencé à
apprendre voir ou bobby fischer on sait
que c'est vers 7 ans aussi qu'il a
commencé relativement tard au milieu
oui et ça n'a pas empêché d'atteindre en
note d'ailleurs un projet atteint très
haut niveau mais bon tout à fait
franchement j'ai jamais réussi à
atteindre le niveau des thèmes bacrot et
ses terrains et disons que j'ai payé un
peu aussi les pots cassés de du fait que
j'étais un peu un pionnier et que voilà
ça c'est le pionner en a pas on est
monté puis on s'est arrêté est ce
qu'elle est base était peut-être passé
là sont pas assez solides bien sûr pour
moi c'était déjà pas mal oui aujourd'hui
on a en france une trentaine de grands
maîtres 25 30
tu sais pas brouiller avec audrey
d'entre 20 et 30 blessés ça donc c'est
beaucoup puisque rampe et finement les
années 80 quand on y en avait 1 alors là
c'est s était déjà génial maintenant
c'est devenu presque honte roman noir m
au col n'a revu quasiment fait pas comme
maintenant quand même pas effectivement
c'est que 20 ou 30 grand maître en
france pour à peu près donc
cinquante plus de cinquante mille
licenciés et on peut considérer
plusieurs millions de joueurs loisirs en
france est mort à quatre mais cinq
joueurs loisirs
alors on va parler aujourd'hui olivier
du tournoi du cap d'agde que tu connais
bien puisque tu l'a commentée dans les
années passées oui c'est un tournoi qui
est organisé et financé donc par le ccas
comité d'entreprise d'edf qui qui
propose une partie spectacle avec des
stars donc il a notamment karpov est
venue cette année on a vu aussi etienne
bacrot était là il ya des magnus
carcelle notre nouvelle star mondiale
des échecs norvégien qui maintenant à 16
ans je crois et qui a été plus jeunes
grands maîtres du monde qui
extraordinaire ce gars est dans leur
décision
16 ans il fait déjà partie presque du
top 20 ouais on dit de lui que c'est le
nouveau fischer on va attendre et on va
attendre que mais c'est vrai qu'il a
l'air costaud c'est disons dans le hall
dans le tournoi la liste des
participants on peut voir différents
aspects des échecs qui peuvent attirer
les spectateurs donc les anciennes
gloires où il apporte un carport qu'il
faut savoir karpov joue presque plus à
l'heure actuelle il joue plus beaucoup
et joue quelques rapides où il reste
quand même assez redoutable mais sinon
ici un peu plus bayat européenne il ya
pas beaucoup d'enseignements regard des
anciennes gloires n'a qu'une menace de
taille quand même est encore à l'essai
on peut même pas faire d'autres pensions
alors parce que je joue toujours à un
niveau exceptionnel voit qu'on a eu on a
été invité les meilleurs joueurs
français
oui donc enfin les meilleurs les disons
très prometteur laurent frayssinet
etienne bacrot et maxime vachier-lagrave
ailleurs s'il faut par contre un
problème taux de jeunes femmes
très forte un très très fortes qui sont
pour la tous des grands maîtres masculin
avec on arrondit pas dans le match
truand bagarre ça on est bien obligé
parce qu'il a toutes catégories toutes
catégories catégorie c'est mieux non
mais c'est épatant m masculin ma part on
n'entreprend elle a droit aux comprends
pas ce que c'est les filles on a les
très grandes stars internationales
jeunes qui sont assurées radjabov est
sûre car yakine ecalles seine est donc
dans une sur le plateau sont réunis les
trois meilleurs jeunes à part étienne
oui à peu près les plus prometteurs je
pense que c'est le meilleur
donc c'est pour ça que le plateau et du
pam m ouais c'est à dire que dans cette
liste
à mon avis on se trompe pas si on dit on
pourrait peut-être ajouter un jour comme
un média rohff
mais kate j'ai un peu plus âgées aussi
on se trompe pas je pense y ont dit
qu'un des trois sera champion du monde
oui c'est très très probable et quand
ils vont faire des matches même entre
eux probablement oui c'est tout à fait
brasser la cdc la relève on peut voir
des surprises arrivent et notamment de
pays émergents comme la chine ou l'inde
qui met quand même le paquet on voit de
plus en plus où on peut très bien voir
resurgir en génie aussi assez rapidement
par exemple chez les femmes on peut
noter qu'il ya une jeune chinoise la de
12 ans un wiki exceptionnel et oui mais
moi je l'avais vu quand elle avait dix
ans déjà et j'avais été la voir je lui
avais dit qu'elle serait championne du
monde mais j'avais pas dix femmes ou
hommes
mais est ce qu est ce qu elle a le
niveau des jeunes
des jeunes garçons plus que le niveau
pouvoir et 12 en a déjà 2500 donc donc
qu'elles savent très bien où ils fans
parce que c est ce qu est ce que tu
penses
on voit bien que dans le monde générale
on se retient tout le monde et chaque
année de plus en plus et les femmes
prennent le pouvoir que ce soit
économique ou politique
on voit un homme politique on peut
parler de hillary clinton par exemple
états unis d'un merkel ou envoi en
france avec ségolène royal dans le
niveau niveau au même économique on voit
de plus en plus de femmes à la tête des
grandes entreprises en france on n'a pas
une auberge en qui j arrive à on égale à
d'autres au signalement aux échecs il ya
judit polgar évidemment qui a été la
pionnière voilà ben bella elle est au
top top mais derrière ça pousse venir
maintenant on a des grands maîtres
féminin qui arrive tout projet la barre
dès 2006 donc ça y est qu'ils rentrent
dans le top 100 toutes catégories mais
je veux dire autant que judith c'était
une météore autant là ça a l'air de
venir du bas avec beaucoup de monde quoi
c'est dire qu'il ya de plus en plus
grand est féminin déjà au-dessus 2005 et
donc on peut supposer que d'ici 3 4 ans
il y en aura quelques unes au dessus de
2006 je crois que les chinoises
notre héros des jo à sont les chinois
s'est elle arrive en paquet si vous
voulez vous qu'ils ont déjà oxo eia
où il fan qui n'était pas présente au
cap d'agde mais qui de public français a
eu l'honneur de voir pendant le match
france chine qui a eu lieu à paris au
mois de septembre elle était la pluie
donc parmi effectivement judit polgar à
son époque c'était vraiment une
exception c'est toujours toujours aller
moi je serais je serais pas étonné que
d'ici quelques années on est
10 15 20 au dessus de 1600 salariés dont
là peut-être une femme champion du monde
pourquoi attendant les possibles sont
évidemment que c'est possible mais ce
que ces présidents les dix ans c'est ça
la question parce que ce soit possible
ça c'est clair mais dans les dix ans euh
oui pourquoi pas oui fans pourquoi pas
donc maintenant à voir en tout cas
alors autant je pense que mon instinct
elle sait pas encore mûr elles sont bons
mais bon dans les dix ans dix quinze ans
c'est possible
enfin on peut l'imaginer autant autant
les amendes homme-machine les femmes les
pardons les matches je vais arriver les
machos machines ont fait beaucoup parler
d échec au niveau mondial
on se rappelle de caspar audible mais
alors s'il y avait un match de phase
finale de championnat du monde ça serait
tout à fait aussi intéressant je pense
que vraiment ça ça passionnant et tout
le monde quoi
oui il y aura vraiment des discussions
dans les foyers parce que les femmes
sont plus sensibles que les hommes
oui non mais enfin tout cas là il y
aurait quelque chose de clair quoi pas
mais en tout cas on approche de plus en
plus de ça on voit là avec les échecs il
ya sept ce baromètre cette édition qui
permet de juger c'est pour résumer le
problème c'est qu'elle ait des auditeurs
doivent comprendre c'est qu'en fait si
les jeunes femmes n'étaient pas aussi
nombreuses c'est que dans les clubs avec
des hommes de quoi tout simplement oui
donc on ne rentrait pas assez un monde
marin dans un je crois que le
pourcentage en france c'est de l'ordre
de 2%
ça monte donc je pense qu'il ya déjà un
effort gamme harry sebag maintenant
france pour que ça marche a d'un côté
bon des jeunes femmes qui ont
la volonté pour tenir et s'entraîner
comme comme tout le monde et puis aussi
de la volonté des clubs on voit en
france par exemple championnat beaucoup
book de plus en plus d'encouragements
pour les échecs féminin féminin alors
bien handicap ça c'est à mon sens c'est
que on ne voit pas pourquoi aux échecs
durée des compétitions féminines et
masculines
alors pour l'instant c'est à mon sens
alors on attend ça reflète peut-être
c'est est mieux que ça c'est un débat
qui est oui non mais sur le fond on voit
bien que j'ai dit polgar d'ailleurs je
vous passe chez les femmes donc sur le
fond je pense que tout le monde est
d'accord là dessus mais en attendant que
les femmes atteignent le niveau des
hommes je crois que c'est aussi normal
pour l'instant que ce soit mais je pense
que quand il y aura un pourcentage de
femmes important dans une compétition
mixte je dirais on laissera tomber les
commissions des mines m
voilà c'est un point de vue assez normal
le mien est un peu différent au sens où
je crois que finalement ça les desserts
de jouer parce qu'en fait ce qu'ils
lisent pas c'est qu'il ya des
compétitions fille est tout petit scion
xb mix mix remix bon voilà donc en fait
les filles elles sont bien contentes de
gagner les compétitions filles où ils
seraient elles sont très contente de
gagner et finalement ils n'atteignent
jamais elles sont contentes de leur
niveau qu'est qui est pas très fort oui
oui je parle pas d exception aujourd'hui
mais qui monte qui monte
bon voilà ça c'est un petit monde il
n'offrait pas mais ça les empêche pas de
faire des conditions si elle a été
divisée par habitué à faire les
compétitions mixtes à mon avis assez
considérable mais c'est peut-être elle
même qui veulent pas le faire aussi
donc voilà parce que c'est ouvert de
toute façon si ouvert donc bon en
attendant que même je crois à moins que
le niveau va même par exemple marie ce
bague
zouk avec les cavalières sont tout à
fait joue très bien donc toutes les
filles qui sont fortes il ajouté alors
on va voir aujourd'hui sur ce ton un cap
d'agde qui est fait sous une manière
spectacle aussi qui habite plein de
joueurs à faire des open voyante à
gauche on tutu a déjà commenté
donc on l'a dit la finale on va voir la
finale
enfin une partie de la finale une partie
de la finale qui s'est jouée donc
c'était des matches il y avait des
poules au départ un mois en gros on peut
dire qu'ils favorisent sont qualifiés et
d'ailleurs ce sont les jeunes qui sont
allés en finale les jeunes stars c'est
radjabov qui jouent la finale face à
kariat qui n'ont contenir ces deux
grandes mégastar jeunes dans le monde
ces jeunes joueurs ont moins de 20 ans
et sont déjà dans le top 20 mondial quoi
on y verra déjà box et 2729 et klaas
knot 2006 a dû encore augmenter et donc
car yakine il est à 2690 chrono donc
voilà donc ils désiraient il est loué
dans le top 20 mais on peut regretter qu
etienne pas confirmé sur ce tournoi
etienne il a été éliminé par radjabov
voilà donc voilà donc bon sinon il a il
était dans les airs est au premier abord
qu il voulait jouer un match championnat
du monde face à topalov seul truc qui
s'est fixé à s'est pas fait c'est
topalov a perdu face à kramnik on
faisait pas prêt je savais pas il
n'avait pas pris vis à vis ils voulaient
parce qu'il ya une nouvelle règle qui
prévoyait qu'on pouvait défier le
champion du monde si on a mené 1
millions de dollars de prix donc on va
en attendant il a eu sa finale face à
kaia king notre ami radjabov voilà et on
voit sur 7 sur cette partie là donc la
partie aura jiabao à l'eiblen face face
à khanaqinne qui est la deuxième partie
du match car il fallait donc eu 4 au
premier coup olivier donc ça c'est un
coup
ce que tu connais le répertoire a déjà
beau fils oui mais radjabov en fait
c'est un joueur qui travaille avec
d'autres grands maîtres non à un grand
maître français qui travaille énormément
avec radjabov qui s'appelle igor nataf
et qui est pourvoyeur d'idées dans les
ouvertures
tout à fait formidable donc là c'est du
très très haut niveau et donc très
souvent quand vous vous allez voir les
ouvertures de radjabov il ya la petite
patte de la taxe qui traîne alors on va
voir ça alors c'est simple car les kings
sicilienne on est en partie rapide et
foulera oui alors rade il faut préciser
que radjabov il a des répertoires
parties rapides et des répertoires
partie nantis joue pas forcément
n'amèneront rien mais ça se comprend
d'ailleurs parce que en partie rapide on
peut jouer des warrants peut-être plus
risqués mais on a moins de risques entre
guillemets puisque jean marc et puis
aussi ils veulent garder leur leur
honneur de les nouveautés c'est du
travail donc ils veulent aussi garder
des choses importantes pour des matchs
ultérieure pas bête parce qu'on soit là
la ceca retrouva difficulté de trouver
des choses nouvelles maintenant ça
demande beaucoup de travail donc ce sera
un peu gaspillé là il va montrer quelque
chose de nouveau justement voilà donc
des six ici on est dans une alors qu'est
ce que ce qu'est ce qui se passe nous
faut qu'il était inopportun
attention non mais tu as un micro
cravate et en veste
on va attendre c'est pas grave j'aurais
dû alors l'étagé les thèmes repris alors
alors des six ici l'art donc c'est la
cécilienne c'est la société 4 d-4d aux
grands cavaliers prend cavaillé six dons
classiques qui a pris qu'à laisser trois
à six on est dans la fameuse je ne me
rappelais le nom parce que j'investis
sienne j'adore la neige d'or voilà une
petite roue classique on l'a déjà vu
plein fois nommé ronald notamment donc
c'est classique c'est le petit coup qui
la petite pointe on empêche vont
contrôler la classe b 5 pour jouer des
cinq plus tard dans la partie et se
libérait souvent avec fougue et cette
derrière on va voir la suite alors fou
j'ai cinq rangées 5 c c'est un choix
déjà l'oeil déjà c'était ce que les
côtés ce qui était considéré à l'époque
dans les années 70 comme ce qui pouvait
mettre en danger
la conception est sur moi ce qui est
intéressant c'est que on a un retour
maintenant eux
on revisite les anciennes variantes oui
en essayant de
avec le travail de trouver des choses
qui remettent en selle des trucs qu'on
croyait bien sûr bien sûr donc fou g5
c'est une arme ultra dangereuse quand
comme l'a fait chronique avec la défense
de berlin voilà par exemple
pour lui les remontées carrément un
arriéré carrément remonter au 19e siècle
alors fou g5 donc on va voir dans cette
partie que bon
car yakine choisi le 6 on a un problème
qui on a un portable qui sonne on a
oublié de le déconnecter face est pas
grave alors 6 ici donc la plus classique
petit petit centre anormal pour lewis un
classique jusqu'ici mal rien à dire f4
logique aussi f4 l'idée c'est de mettre
évidemment la dame en f3 et de faire le
grand rapidement possible d'amis sip et
mettre le pion ici pour éviter tout
bloquer le pion derrière ensuite on va
faire le grand roque et ensuite on
développera avec g4 g5 5 sous des
trois-tours h heure voilà donc le le
problème disons que la vente
problématique ici c'est la vente du pied
empoisonné eh bien on va le voir la
fameuse varane que jouer bobby fischer
voilà la variante la baisse toujours
d'actualité qui posent une problématique
licites ou surplomber 2 r on va les
noirs en fait dans la plupart des ventes
du pion empoisonné se retrouve à avoir
jouer un deux trois quatre cinq six
coups de pions et trois coupes dame pour
aller prendre un pion b2 et donc ce qui
est incroyable c'est que c'est un défi
aux échecs finalement puisqu'on donne ci
coûte développement pratiquement pour un
client pour un pion et on n'a jamais
réussi à les réfuter
oui donc alors il ya eu quand même la
fla
peut-être la partie la plus célèbre sur
ceux sur ceux sur cette variante là on a
quand même voir la suite parce que c'est
ce qui a été jouée dam des deux donc on
laisse le pion prix nous laisse pas
perdre de temps et après d'emprunt
bellion nixon qui empoisonnent et
puisqu'après tombe bien on gagne le
temps sur la dame qui vend à 3 oui hélas
tout le débat démarre ici et on a eu
la partie peut être la plus célèbre
c'est la fameuse partie fischer c'est
parce qu'ils fischer exactement 72 to
championnat du monde qui est une des
seules parties que fisher a vraiment
perdu de ce match là on peut dire
puisque les autres partis perdu une part
forfait et l'autre sur une erreur bête
de sa part
la seule partie perdue qui était une
grosse grosse préparation aux
soviétiques avec les blancs face à ces
deux variantes que confectionner fischer
donc été un peu une variante que
finalement ce parce qu'il a gagné plus
tôt à l'analyse chez lui que sur
l'échiquier
oui oui
bon on sait pas où ça s'est arrêté et
disant qu'il avait développé les tours
bien plutôt la conception et cavaliers b
3 mai
dans la part variante avec tours ben
justement le coût 1,5 choisi par un job
voilà cent fois ci par un câble c'est
pendant ce qu'on a cru qui réfutait
qu'ils étaient en mesure de réfuter puis
l'expérience a montré que les noirs sont
sans arrêt en train de courir après s'en
sortent
voilà donc ici on peut enfin faire on va
voir si on prend des saints pardon si on
prends 200
le cavalier d'attaqué faut le boucher
cavale et 17 si on regarde un petit peu
la position vous accueilleront les
blancs ont plus que jouer fou ckt petit
rock
alors maintenant exemple c4 les petits
rock et n'importe quel débutant dit elle
trouverait cette position complètement
injouable pour rejoindre pour énorme
puisqu'ils ont rien développé on lit
avec oslo paix contre un deux trois
quatre cinq pièces et bientôt petit rock
ça fait beaucoup de pièces en jeu avec
beaucoup de menaces potentielles
voilà donc brice il y avait de nombreux
coups qui ont été utilisés le coup
ces quatre étant le cookie été pendant
longtemps considéré comme le plus
dangereux
et puis il ya le pion à 5 ans prise
voilà alors on donne tout évidemment on
peut dire 'ok c'est la passion on donne
tous les pions les pièces voilà d'accord
et là on apprend d'ailleurs aux élèves
que dans une position comme ça un des
buts en pl date un grand maître
justement witz qui peut mater quelqu'un
au milieu de l'échiquier sur donc c'est
très très dangereux très dangereux pas
jouer ouais ouais mais bon faut quand
même avoir le sens de l'attaqué faut pas
parce qu'il faut pas perdre de temps
pour pas perdre haletant alors là il
choisit une variante la vanne touche
avec camaïeu quatre cavaliers 4 donc
des noirs jouent ce qui est considéré
comme le meilleur coup à chis encore à
schiste considéré comme le meilleur coup
sourit alors on va voir le foot doit
aller en h4 pour garder le contrôle d'un
gagne la diagonale pour incarner le
contrôle dans cette diagonale et quart
et akin choisi de rentrer dans la ligne
qui était considéré comme la meilleure
c'est un sans doute je t'arrête juste au
lit sans doute donc l'idée notamment six
cavaliers prendre 5
on peut toujours par exemple cavaliers
voilà exacte des cinq à battre la dame
le car il est en prise oui si on prend
mais il ya d'amd vite matt kim
exactement avec le fou voilà voilà
l'idée de garder le contrôle de la
diagonale
ça empêche cavaliers cavalières 5 voilà
par examen on pourrait peut-être trouvé
aussi d'autres d'autres découvertes tout
aussi intéressante alors là il a choisi
d'apprendre
alors ça c'est toujours répertorié par
les théories donc c'est toujours
théorique
oui pour moi ces jeunes joueurs qui
connaissent sur le bout des doigts
voilà et
une des idées c'est que
sur par exemple le coq était considérée
ici comme le coup le plus dangereux
c'était tour b3 et c'est le justement le
gmi igor nataf qui a mis au goût du jour
le coutour d1 qui ma foi a l'air aussi
complètement naturel puisqu'on ne
délaisse pas la première rangée et ont
créé des menaces
aussi sur la colonne des potentiels
voilà d'accord on va voir ça donc on
voit radjabov qui reprend une idée
d'igor juin j'avais vérifié et savent
été joué en 2002 d'accord parigot
parigote donc ce qu'ils doivent se
préparer contre un job on ferait bien de
regarder partie d'igor aussi est à mon
avis car yakine est tout à fait préparé
ici il n'arrive pas sans biscuit comme
une récréation explique mans son plein
le coût principal je pense que ces
cavaliers c6 ici le prix principal dans
ces cas les six mais ici il choisit de
jouer d'un bep de dons qu'il avait son
idée avant la partie d'un bep 2 donc
c'était une autre idée on va voir la
suite à une menace bien sûr
il menace bien sûr food et 4 et on
attrape la grippe à faire après ces
trois années obligé d'échanger les dames
par exemple imaginons que les blancs
jouent un coup comme fou c4 c4 par
exemple il y aurait fourbe et catella
des quatre oeuvres que la dame est cloué
ici l'adar il faut sur le roy on est
forcé de jouer ces trois faut jouer ces
trois et ça ait changé d'un échange des
dames et donc la très difficile attaqué
sans les dames on a pas d'attaqué on a
deux pions de moins il n'ya plus qu'à
des fossettes et la partie est mal
engagée hollande a jugé tout à fait donc
d'enlever deux dames 3 donc pour éviter
ce fou les canariens nous voilà donc
surtout des catéchètes maintenant
j'aurai tout simplement c3 quoi ces
trois enquêtes un coût et il en
deviendrait le temps du temps voilà 15
ans du temps donc c'est pourquoi fous
ces cinq est joué donc ça cloue un petit
peu ce qu'elle valait sur la dame est
menacée peut-être cavalli ces six voire
augmenter la pression c'est férié donc
la fouille de fonds et 2 et
qu'effectivement quelqu'un m'a dit si ce
qu'avait laissé si ces jouets attaque
une fois deux fois trois fois avec la
dame donc il ya il ya tout à fait il ya
menace de gamme de pièces donc sa force
le coup suivant
des blancs qui est le coup c'est 3 voilà
ici c'est roanne qui consolide ici le
cavalier ce pion étant bien protéger à
la fois par la dame mais par le cavalier
pas de souci donc là alors encore en
coupe dame de la part des noirs j'ai un
peu des doutes sur ce coup alors voilà
c'est que qu'est-ce que alors là les
noirs auront peut-être bu mais peut-être
et les tendres ok je sais pas
est ce que les noirs parce qu'il ya une
autre possibilité ici que 15 joueurs de
nage de horse se doit de regarder ce
serait mais ça ne marche pas ici
est-ce qu'on peut jouer le coup
cavaliers prend 1,5 paris flop leurs
alliés ou l'autre celui ci au genou
l'autre à ce moment là on va se heurter
très probablement à la réplique
cavaliers france et 6 en laissant la
dame emprise on laisse la dame emprise
du fouet ces bandes am on voit l'éternel
menace de tour des huit maths et là on
voit bien l'idée de 1 à 2 tours d un
toujours avec le fouet le cavalier donc
voilà et si on prend avec le canada
français 5 et là on gagne le fou donc ça
c'est la petite
voilà donc ce coût n'est pas possible ce
coût ce coup ici n'est pas possible
alors peut-être une possibilité tout
simplement ces échanges et pardon et
changer car si on échange les blancs
vont prendre du plomb c'est vrai que
cavaler prend des cas c'est vrai
qu'après pions prendre les quatre les
noirs que je vais gagner un temps j'en
fus bekkat échec après un coup comme roy
f2 bref de bien sûr pas oublié le jour
ça fait très peur parce que maintenant
menace par exemple tour b 1
les pitous reprend des cats et cavaliers
dont celle avec le fou derrière voilà
c'est
via le fou le carrier qui peut les
peut-être en d6 il vous est pris au fait
ya beaucoup de menaces quoi alors
surtout au niveau de la conception
normalement quand on prend ce pion du
centre de le pion des deux permet de les
noirs en fait on a un très fort centre
et le pian et 5 est faible alors qu'ici
le pionner 5 est bien protégé donc les
deux pions en fait de plus son bessette
et as his way et avant que l'on se serve
de ses pions largement le temps de se
faire mater oui oui c'est ça et tant de
finale
voilà tant qu'on peut pas je dirais
contre attaquer directement sur le
centre en prenant ce point 5 à ce moment
là ça va mal ça va mal se passer
les blancs ont beaucoup de temps pour
construire leur attaque donc c'est la
clé de la position voilà donc les
changeant des quatre ce serait une
erreur ce serait une erreur
positionnelle en fait il faut nous
laisser ce pion faible voila voila
d'accord
donc on va avoir loupé donc le ku'damm à
trois finales dames alors bien sûr il
menace peut-être toujours un peu la même
chose mais là ils veulent y veut
échanger échanger des femmes exactement
voilà l'offre en fait j'ai même une
menace fait la dame n'est pas protégé
alors ont par contre quelque chose qui
est inquiétant c'est que sur foot sur
cavaliers prend des cas tout fou prend
des cats
on peut tout à fait à mon avis là j'ai
pas vu la suite de la partie mais
sacrifier tout simplement la qualité
avec tours prend des quatre déjà et
imaginons les cases noires c'est pas un
grand chose d'avoir cette qualité
imaginons petit rock on peut très bien
imaginer pas rien de sûr cavaliers
points des quatre qu'on va jouer tout
reprend des quatre ans aucun problème
c'est ce qui a été joué un petit manque
alors que sur cavani prendre les quatre
on jouerait tout reprendre les quatre
c'est l'idée peut imaginer tout
reprendre et 4 effectivement pour par
prendre du plomb et à voir d'ailleurs la
dame serait entré sur fou prin sur vous
prend on fait d'un prendre comme francs
alors évidemment là que tout se joue sur
les cases doigt une des grandes
difficultés bien noir vos clés quasiment
faut protéger son attaque est partout
voilà les pièces blanches le pion le
cavalier la dame dont six occasions à
pile à tous et dans le jeu sur f c est
aussi ça fait beaucoup beaucoup et on
pourrait croire que eh bien il suffit
finalement 2
ça peut faire petit roquet de s'échapper
mais quand on fait le coup petit rock et
appris beaucoup de défenseurs sur les
cases doigts et on va pouvoir attaquer
avec cavaliers m6 échec est fou quand m6
on a on est on a toutes les pré
conditions pour qu'une attaque marche le
surnomment les faiblesses on a tout ce
qu'il faut et envoie les spectateurs la
torah 8 oui et le fou civile exactement
se garder des spectateurs les outils
monétaires des références lasserre qui
ne jouent pas ils n'ont pas d'activité
dans le même temps la partie donc là
petit rock petit rock et voilà et
maintenant c'est parti
évidemment classique et l'arrivée à qui
tout à fait normal c'est déjà la tacc
tout de suite donc c'est la même
configuration il ay là il a simplement
fait petits roms tout de suite il n'a
pas pris la qualité ici et là on est
dans la même configuration qu'à relief 6
échecs toile à fait normal tout à fait
dont j'allais chercher cette partie on
n'a pas peur de la prise du port par an
j'aurais pu prendre donc si imaginons
sûr que l'on prend largement j'aurais
tendance à dire
françois fillon prend soin fou prend
comprend et on voit que le pion à chis
est faible par exemple sur pions prendre
menace déjà dame j'ai trois échecs par
exemple on menace g7 massy et matt damon
associe d'emprunt 6 et 11 face aux
menaces effectivement en même temps on
menace effectivement dame prend 1,6 avec
mathis inky à suivre donc si le roi ne
peut plus échapper il peut pas
s'échapper puis on voit très bien que la
tour peuvent venir lance très vite en
plus aussi c'est très difficile à
défendre
c'est indéfendable et alors si les noirs
jouent au roi hamad achoui 3 h 8
alors est-ce qu'on peut pas faire un
coup comme dames 4 par exemple pour
forcer on a plusieurs types d' attaque
on adam cac pour essayer ou d'amd 3 pour
essayer de forcer la prise donc dans le
iv ici avec l'as monaco match on aurait
aussi
la possibilité est ce qu'on a la
possibilité de jouer un coup comme on va
voir dames quatre salaires fort
effectivement table quatre menaces mat
ici tout simplement donc sa force sa
force la prise donc la prise est ce
qu'on va pas juger si ce qui serait qui
serait un suicide puisque sans doute
surgit si l'on peut prendre 17 jeux où
il faut six échecs ou et sur cavaliers
prend cavaliers et sur la il faut
préfère qu'elle allait prendre un geste
est en train de me demander tout reprend
j'ai envie de jouer tous réussissent
comme ça autour mois m6 et leurs forces
pour faire tour pour la chine échec
foued six échecs tout reprend celui de
fou prend et ensuite dans la nasse voilà
est-ce que ça ça a l'air difficile ça a
l'air difficile comment défendre ça il
faudrait revenir peut-être avec le
cavaliere voilà on a cavaliere est alors
c'est une position
nous c'est difficile de savoir aussi
rapidement le verrou et noir pour
l'essence les blancs ont rien sacrifier
la énormément à égalité là il ya collé
toujours les pions les pions un petit
peu de retard mais on peut dire que la
partie veut la partie continue alors
c'est une possibilité
sinon l'autre possibilité c'est
reprendre directement 2
avec la dame au lieu de dames 4 on
pourrait aussi envisager des coups comme
c'est d'amener la tour en d'abord un jeu
alors elle qu'est la f4 bon il ya
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de choses
données beaucoup de choses mais beaucoup
joué mais c'était peut-être qu'il
fallait jouer en tout cas un score de
toute façon oui sans publicité une
partie rapide
c'est une partie rapide oui on peut se
demander quelque chose qui est difficile
à défendre finale des france arrête son
analyse parce que où s'arrêtent les
savoirs à la maison de quartier qui
n'est finalement ici on ne sait pas trop
et sans le savoir la comme ça j'aurais
l'impression qu'il vaut mieux jouer roi
je suit alors on va voir ce qu'il a joué
ça a été rapide
ça a été rapide tout à fait alors on va
voir ça ce roi il n'a pas joué non il
adaptable les pourriels c'est terrible
alors il fallait voir cavaler francs il
ajoute qu'à vallée prend hélas en fou
prend tout simplement voilà alors faut
prendre
qu'est-ce qui se passe évidemment
imaginons aussi les noirs prennent
évidemment alors le premier tout de
suite c'est que le rock on voit bien que
le roi est complètement me diront la
même chose ajoute t on quand voilà tout
simplement ici tout simplement qu on
prend un f6 menace c'est simple on
menace d'armes francis et on n'associe
d'alger trois échelles suivi de maths
donc très difficile à défendre voire
même impossible un peu ferme il n'y a
pas deux mais pas d'échec direct mais ce
pion est énorme
ce plan est énorme il contrôle une case
g7 indéfendable pour les noirs et ses
maths c'est matt rapide tout simplement
donc il a joué notre ami car yaqing
cavale et prend des quatre le thème déjà
il sait qu'il a perdu
oui là c'est foutu complète non monsieur
donc en fait la risée dame un salaire
allait vraiment dans une préparation
quoi c'est la préparation qui fait la
différence la wii u nantes en vo ça
paraît très spectaculaire on donne
beaucoup de pions mais l' attaque avec
cavaliers m6 échec avec toutes les
pièces et les complètement classique
allégations
rien ne dit rien de moins en avait parlé
comme une pas la partie du siècle mais
j'aime avoir brossé une combinaison
classique oui c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'on voit bien que la toutes les pièces
blanches sont du coup sont du côté roy
et que le roi est un peu et solide en
défense et que c'est le genre de
sacrifices qu'on a envie de faire
voilà là on tombe vraiment dans la
problématique quand vous allez prendre
les pions et que vous êtes en retard de
développement et votre adversaire peut
très bien sacrifier dû beaucoup de
matériel et vous mettez vous mater et
vous matin et vous reste effectivement
qu'une tour est un fou de plus mais vous
pouvez alors vous relevez entre les plus
folles voilà le ventre plein
voilà un mieux vaut mourir le ventre
plein comme on dit souvent c'est une
maxime hodée chacun un kit à peu après a
autant prendre toutes les pièces mais
non mais là bon alors on va y va quand
même être tenté une défense son tour
prendre des quatre faut prendre des
quatre là la dame on est obligé de toute
façon puisque la dame ici est clouée sur
le roi il fallait qu'il faille
absolument prendre le fou et on pouvait
pas non plus encore une fois prendre du
plomb à cause de tout à fait intérêt
donc dans prend est obligatoire est
toujours là la menace tout de suite
c'est sans doute d'alger 4 voilà avec
faiblesse énorme surgit cette famille
pour forcer g6 si on peut apprendre que
simplement je me fous des projets si
c'est dû apprendre que takashi sont plus
jouer food et 3 on peut éventuellement
mener la tour à l'attaqué et c'est bien
sûr donc ici les mains car yakine y être
allé un peu perdu quoi ont finalement
fait et il a planché ce que je voulais
juste revenir tout petit peu en arrière
alors on prend des claques d'apprendre
des quatre gpra ici voilà donc il a
choisi de prendre l'eau de mourir le
ventre plat donc maintenant bien sûr
pions prend qui on prend on a stoppé
leurs écailles voilà madame g 4 échecs
suivi de maths angers7
voilà donc c'est très simple menace est
très simple sur trois ans ou un cool
comme rouach 8 longs jours est tout
simplement d'un f4 et c'est tout bête
quoi dames 3 4 1 2 et voilà un mec alors
on avait trois peut-être pour garder la
tour libre c'est pareil d'un mètre carré
c'est la même chose ah non parce qu'il
adams et cinq échecs donc il faut
empêcher dams et saillants et dames ces
cinq échecs donc séparé la dame
reviendra en défense il faudrait faire
attention tout petit peu précis en fait
en tout qui n'a mené son agréable 3
empêche les chèques et la menace tout
simplement il m'a répression il faut
être très précis mais tout à fait donc
là ça oblige d'ailleurs deux des
parisiens soit acheter un neuf ou des
trois émetteurs dans le fou qui vient de
jouer son petit rôle échec
et là c'est terminé puisque si le roi du
g8 et bien mg3 échec au roi a suivi un
objet cette note est sûre h sera à
schwyz d'armes francis suivi du mat
aussi donc il faut être précis il faut
être précis donc gpra m6 qui apprécie
tout simplement comme quoi des fois les
coups les plus forts sont les plus
calmes il faut voir que les menaces sont
parfois souvent plus forte que
l'exécution voilà c'est ça qui était
vacciné connu un arôme mise au bik notre
maître à tous donc ici c'est à la
galerie couverte artaq cette attaque au
vert c'est un aphorisme je crois de
terrain couvert c'est pas c'est pas
novice qui aurait dit ça bah disons que
là c'est là disons que si une attaque
brutale un bon alors il a sciemment cinq
dames à cinq semaines pour pour pouvoir
je pose l'anecdote par rapport à ça de
la menace est plus forte que l'exécution
c'est le fameux cigare là oui il y avait
brel le
le joueur a dû non seulement à quelques
miles a raconté j'ai pas si je dois
aussi peut-être attaque au vernet mais
je sais plus qui le dit l'auteur mais
l'idée c'est qu'il est en train de jouer
une partie et sur l'adversaire pose une
cigarette mais aussi garé à côté de
l'iss de son échiquier en fait comme
s'il allait finalement et il n'est pas
content on fait islem il va voir
l'arbitré du 10e
écoutez c'est scandaleux c'est interdit
de fumer mon adversaire fume je ne sais
pas d'où viennent ces conditions à
l'habitat va voir la taille dominé fume
pas je dis oui vous savez aux échecs la
menace est plus forte que l'expression
voilà c'est qu'elle est allée assez
connue elle est allée cité par je crois
par nicolas giffard dans ce fameux livre
la fabuleuse histoire des champions
d'ailleurs dans les années 80 ont fumé
pendant les parties en fumée dans les
parties - tout à fait alors que
maintenant on est contraint de sortir à
bassens et interdit complètement alors
h4 le couple et sa clef le couple est
alors intéressant l'idée contrôle et jc
mais là c'est pour empêcher la dame ici
devenir soit 11,5 pour après l'assaut
vers une bonne d'un bon défenseur et
après on pourra ramener les autres
pièces voilà qu'il faut absolument
empêcher la dame de revenir
et là on menace mais d'am-dam j'ai
quatre échecs suivi du mat
sachant que la dame noire ne peut pas
venir en défense les suroît âge suit
toujours les mêmes choses où j'aurai
tout simplement d'un f k 12 m3 et on va
mettre 4 alors rouach est donc la
classique moment là tu m'envoies pas
trop l'idée de droits le chef puisque on
va pouvoir jouer ou de cdd les
contraintes de donner la dame
il est contraint de donner la dame aussi
ça il veut donner la main pour un fou de
maintenant il n'y a plus le choix en
fait il peut plus empêcher
imaginons roi à droite 8 mai ce cas la
dame 3me droit ou une m3 c'est plus
précis ps3 qui ont évité les échecs
voilà c'est plus clair menace d'un point
6 comment défendre on peut pas was set
et on revient fou des trois échecs et ça
on va revenir la même chose donc ici
rouages c'est tout simplement tout de
suite on approche de la fin la foulée
trois échecs
voilà et là il ya plus de choix puisque
si on va ensuite mais on va se retrouver
avec dame 3 et la menace est imparable
donc il faut tout simplement joué dans
les cinq
voilà avec ça qu'il faut donner la date
voilà donc ils continuent à partie quand
les gardiens qui l'on dit en partie
rapide du reste peut-être
disons que les il faut quand même se
rend compte que les blancs quand même
donné énormément de matane donc il a
encore touré fou pour la dame avait des
pièces morte
voilà donc matériellement la limite avec
les pions c'est jouable mais le problème
c'est comme il ya le pion blanc f6
l'attaquent continuerai ce pion y
continue la balade avec ce pion c'est
terrible et on voit qu'ils jouent précis
jusqu'au bout d'ailleurs qui joue tout
revient je vais alors avec l'idée sans
doute sur fou prend on va peut-être
mettre la tout aussi soit septième art
entraîna la tour exactement toujours
classique alors tour j'évite donc la
petite aussi sa tour en karting fait ce
qu'il peut maintenant 3 2 il n'est pas
pressé de prendre la dame se sont allés
perdu les perdu elle est louée elle
bougera pas n'a pas de coût utile à sec
donc est là il va essayer de créer une
petite diversion avec son pion sait
jamais si l'argument jusqu'au bout 6 à
immobiliser une pièce il peut avoir des
contre chance mais la jolie coup
d'ailleurs pour prendre les matériels g4
très joli petit coup très joli petit
coup classique aussi pour ses prêts oui
c'était l'idée de roy hdr on veut
prendre avec le pion à huy ouvrage de
l'or parce que le roi était que sur la
tour c'est intéressant parce que c'est
je pense que c'est un
une leçon pour les jeunes joueurs et
même confirmé c'est à dire que dans
cette position que gagnante
il faut qu'on cherche les coups les plus
précis il est ce que je le plus vite
qu'il faut de céder rapidement et
souvent psychologiquement quand on est
gagnant on a un peu tendance à relâcher
a relâché il faut pas et on voit là
jusqu'au bout et joue précis c'est ça la
différence entre les supers joueurs
aussi et les autres oui parce qu'on dit
souvent que les parties le client
organisme les parties gagnantes aussi
parce qu'on se relâche
alors là intéressant car à noter que le
coutour projet 4 serait réfuté tout
simplement par un matt rapide avec dame
prend en fait on prendre toujours pas la
dame qui est louée et leur menace de
match et angers 7 c'est imparable mais
rien à faire
très jolie voix la dame donc g4
d'apprendre des trois obligatoire dans
prend avec échec donc en ne prenons pas
la dame au f5
il n'a pas laissé le fou ces huiles de
nos pions arrivée ne se fout toujours
membre le fou est toujours mort je me
demande si la laissera sortir depuis le
début je n'aurais pas sûr d'ailleurs
cela il a préféré effectivement garder
le pion qui bloque le foot et la rúa
suit donc le roi vient ensuite la tour
et cinq super taureau cinq superbes
effets des conclusions de la partie est
vraiment magnifique donc tout simplement
il va amener la tourache il veut il veut
venir acheter et faire un match ici à
six voix il veut faire tout repris ce
matin tout simplement ils bloquent
toujours le pion donc ça c'est les voilà
c'est c'est très élégant
c'est à dire qu'en fait non seulement
ils jouent fort mais en plus il a un jeu
très élégant que vous allez tiens c'est
tout ranger 4 dont angers 4 cfi tour h5
maintenant j'ai l'intention puisqu'il
avoir déjà d'un an maintenant l'arrivée
tour h5 là maintenant menace tout
simplement tout reprend à 6.8 ensuite
d'en prendre dans des huit tout
simplement ma liste matois ou alors
aussi encore d'un h7 peut être quand
même pas se marche pas parce que
temporaire bon voilà des huit matchs est
l'objet de deux des filtres défendre
avec g6 tout ceci c'est maintenant
d'armes échec un échec seulement on peut
la malle ainsi la tour revient c'est
matt avec la tour donc le seul coup ces
trois sets et maintenant tout simplement
le coût d'un de cette superbe
voilà le pau fc a été menacé d'un
premier set suivi de dang tran points
que faire pour la défense est bien le
seul coup qui resterait il abandonne ici
une cariatide parce que si roy g8 dames
8 échecs et 3g lui tout simplement pas
le montrer et il y aurait d'abord huit
échecs l'aube hier le roi est maintenant
dans price cet échec cuite et d'en
prendre et c'est fini
matra renvoi que dans ce diagramme bien
la tour invité la foule ses limites
n'ont toujours pas joué spectateurs
voilà on peut dire voilà voilà partie
spectaculaire
ouais partie oui une petite
spectaculaire et avec des pièces aux
spectatrices
oui voilà donc très très belle partie de
l'europe oui je sais que les bons les
jeunes j'avais quelques élèves qui
jouait le ton à du cap d'agde nossik été
spectateur puisqu'il y avait un open en
même temps que que le tournoi exhibition
wii etc avaient été très impressionné
par cette partie alors douté cradat
radjabov cl non seulement est un jeune
joueur il a battu kasparov
c'est un des rares jeunes 1 il a battu
qu'à spa du kasparov ya
ali dares quand il avait 15 ans
seulement donc c'est un site
'cela va énerver d'ailleurs un format il
est toujours il a ri quand il peut enfin
il était toujours énervé mais mais c'est
vrai qu'on était rappeler de ça et que
il travaille beaucoup il progresser car
yakine aussi dont on avait les noms à
retenir c'est le cas karim qui est
ukrainien il radio pluie états unis si
oui un peu comme kasparov en place par
enfant les azerbaïdjanais
mais non c'est ça s'embrase et riom
galerie variés
donc le dernier le troisième luron c'est
qu'un scène que les norvégiens ya perdu
faut pas oublier notre notre paquereau
notre maxime vachier lagrave quand on
skie très fort ah oui j'oubliais on en a
parlé aussi pourquoi pas chez nous ça
arqués aussi alors là oui avec
prometteur on va atteindre prometteurs
et bien sûr bien sûr et puis ce sens
tout ça ce sont des joueurs en plus qui
s'entraînent sur internet et ça change
complètement le jeu ils apprennent plus
vite ils vont plus vite
voilà merci olivier et je crois que vous
remercie donc tu sera présent pour une
deuxième émission voilà ça serai content
de revenir
ou alors la deuxième mission merci à
tous et à bientôt
oh